putting the fear over Sabbath arias now
I still try well he wasn't there he was
messing with your head it was all in
your mind how do you know he's not
spying on us through Wally right now I
could get a few I have what I need to
keep myself he sent that daddy you
there's no stopping Cemetery
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie new flash
footage let's break it down this is like
though we need to talk about wall-e
episode we might have to have him
committed because he thinks he's seeing
savat our turns out nope he's totally
Wright's avatar climbing out of the
Speed Force so it looks like what's
going on is it somebody one of his
acolytes some other alchemy helps him
escape with the philosopher's stone like
you see getting chucked back into the
Speed Force here with this other version
of alchemy for maybe another universe or
maybe he just selects some other path
see to help him out but there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so also
address some of the questions after last
week's episode but let's talk about this
footage first hands-down my favorite
part of it is when sabotage looks like
he's crawling out of that portal like
it's something out of one of the Ring
movies it's just likes avatar climbing
out of the television to kill all of
them but the weird part here is when
wall-e is hallucinating him earlier in
the episode and you get this vision of
Savitt are without all the CG like I
guess this is what his suit looks like
before they add CG to it and it starts
glowing with Speed Force energy the
advantage of that is that you can
actually see the flash symbol in the
center of his chest here so it just like
suit like all the other evil speedsters
the good speedsters they all have the
flash symbol or at least a version of
the flash symbol reverse flashes is
reversed obviously but there been a
bunch of different variations the only
real exception is the accelerated man I
guess we didn't really get a good look
at his costume just because the scarf
covered it up the waist avatars costume
looks here without all the CG almost
makes it look like molten metal but
based on the way they showed him in
previous episodes like when he had full
CG on he opens his mouth like back in
episode 7 it almost looks like the
costume itself is him like there's not a
man underneath there so we either have a
Daniel West twist where the costume just
kind of like grows out of him in this
freakish way or it's a Full Metal
Alchemist twist where he's become this
soul bonded to this armor or he just
like completely manifested it out of the
Speed Force there did a couple versions
of villains like that but like God speed
in the comics a lot of the flash rebirth
characters can manifest their flash
costumes out of the Speed Force that
might be what's going on here
but because we're in the back half of
the season and we're moving towards like
the last block of episodes it's going to
be focusing more on the Sabbat our plot
lines so like you have a lot of one-off
episodes you have this big two-part
korilla city episode but all of the CW
DC TV shows and really like all the
shows in general tend to focus on their
big bat in the final arc of the season
these are all the tests that you faced
in the past they've helped you learn
lessons that will help you defeat this
villain Julian is back from his family
business in London I think that was just
a clever wink at the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter there was some big
celebration and he went there he does a
lot of make-a-wish Foundation stuff
where he goes and meets fans and stuff
so I think in real life he was on Harry
Potter business and that's why he wasn't
in this episode it has to happen with
really big guest actors like that but I
like the way they explained that it's
the other version of alchemy and it's
not our version so they're not
completely throwing Julian under the bus
like he's still susceptible to sabotage
control wall-e looks like he's the big
problem in this episode though and for
those of you that are wondering I don't
think that there's any chance that they
would ever kill wall-e at the end of the
season there are a couple characters
that I think are totally safe this
season for obvious reasons one is iris
West they're not going to kill her off
the show she's too important for various
character they'll make you think that
they're going to kill they might kill
her in the future a couple times before
the end of the season like Barry's
forced to witness it but whatever ends
up happening at the end of the season
wherever season 4 picks up she'll be
around for the long haul so like when we
get to season 6 season 7 she'll still be
around Wally West as well they're not
going to kill him off the show right
after introducing him but they'll make
you wonder what's going to happen to him
so there are a couple characters that
they can't kill just because they're too
big there are certain big villains like
Grodd he's unkillable he's an Argus now
so they can bring it back in a future
episode like some of the directors of
the Marvel movies they're always
wringing their hands because they're not
allowed to kill their big Marvel
characters you can rake them over the
coals so they're going to be raking
Wally over the coals and he's going to
be going crazy
Daniel west-style just never really
happened to comic book ginger Wally West
just because there was no Barry Allen
that was around when he was fighting
Sava tar he was the only red
suit-wearing version of the flash but
just to address some of the questions
you guys had after last week's episode
there was a couple of twists like with
the garage buy people are like
come it went down the way it did it was
almost like they were stalling just so
that solovar could come that's exactly
what was happening so team flash had the
plan to use Sola bar to defeat Grodd
because they knew that they would never
be able to defeat the guerilla army
there's too many of them and even
fighting one gorilla is really hard for
the flash let alone trying to fight
Korat the problem with fighting Grodd is
that normally a speedster would be
faster than a gorilla but these are
super strong gorillas making them extra
quick so even if the gorillas did not
have speed force powers themselves it
would be a huge trick and the problem is
is that neither Wally or Jesse are
really good fighters yet like they just
started train this is still their
freshman season as speedsters and most
of the people that they face are really
dumb really dumb criminals who aren't
prepared for speedsters so until the
flash family learns to fight really well
together as a cohesive team they're
still going to have problems when they
face really smart villains and I think
there were just a lot of questions about
why the fight went down the way it did
like why did Barry rush Grodd so just
answer questions like that the thing is
is that they were trying to defeat Grodd
in that moment they were actually just
stalling for time till solovar could get
there and take care of brought himself
it was way more efficient to have him
take down garage and have the army stand
out then to have team flash try to kill
themselves defeating every single
gorilla one at a time so it was really
more of a soul of our episode they just
didn't want to reveal that he was going
to be the big twist till that final
moment so that's why they had you think
that team flash was going to be fighting
all these gorillas so they kind of did
stuff like that during Game of Thrones I
know a lot of people complain where it's
like how come you know this character
didn't tell the other character about
the army that was coming in it's just in
the name of a really big TV twist but if
you see it coming then you have a pretty
good idea of how things are going to go
down but the other really cool thing is
that we now know the titles for the next
couple of episodes of the flash so if
you guys want me to talk about those in
the next flash videos that I do next
week just let me know in the comments
because it's all savatage speedforce
comic book stuff we're going to be
pushing into a lot of deep speedforce
mythology this season so if you're big
comic book fans there's going to be a
lot of Easter eggs from the Wally West
arrow in the comics it's going to be a
lot of fun but what's going to happen
later tonight is there's brain
new Aquaman test footage so I'll do a
video for that then I'll post my arrow
video in the morning
there's no legends of tomorrow this week
in my next Legion video we'll post after
the finale airs it just seems like it's
taking a lot of people a while to find
that show so I'm just going to wait a
while before I post another Legion video
but there will be some new Marvel on
Thursday so I'll just update the video
schedule when I post my arrow video
tonight so congratulations to the last
flash ring giveaway winner Kevin Mullins
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video so I will see
you guys later tonight when I post that
arrow video while you wait for that
click here to rewatch that Guardians
trailer and click here for my flash
episode thank you so much for watching
let Sybok I'll see you guys tonight